I'm at what finish what's her finish
unfortunately was in the wrong goal hi
I'm Delhi Ali Tottenham and England
midfielder you've sent in some of your
best and worst misses and goals so I'm
gonna rate them now this is Jimmy looks
like he's going to free-kick oh wow
Jimmy with the back heel free-kick nine
out of ten because I've never seen
anyone do that before
Mason Kelly hold on Mase this doesn't
look very good
Oh step over nice nice yeah that was a
good job he was very young as well so
I'm gonna give him an 8mm seven and a
half yes it's a tough school I don't
think he needs tuning device he looks
like you just need to keep doing that
crane sport FC and what feeling this is
gonna be a Miss it's just like pop ting
oh man what finished
what's the finish unfortunate was in the
wrong goal I've seen a few in training
Eric Dyer usually puts them into one go
7 out of 10
to the finish but the fact that it was
in your own goal makes it an 8 out of 10
Michael Lesnar good music
[Music]
oh then they're not actually as easy as
they look though because it's bubbling
and you'll get a good contact I mean
that's a very mmm no I think that you
ought to score that 10 out of 10 for
Miss maybe he was much vixen this is
Marco Guevara mmm in my professional
opinion that was meant to be across the
NIE not meant that I'm gonna give that
five because that was lucky
marks use any a manager it must have
been him and his playing days
ah what's her finish great fitness I'm
gonna give that a eight out of ten it
was a bit of slow exciting misses out on
the penalty oh my god I'm gonna give him
the name 1ld Mia that's is a kick a lot
of different angling and everything I
unbelievable techniques I'm gonna give
that a nine point two out of ten when I
deem your Junior if you have no name on
him Oh nightmare from the keeper again
he's got no name so I'm gonna call him I
don't know he had to call him because
whoever keeper I say is gonna be not
very happy thanks guys for sending in
your videos there were some very good
goals and some very bad mistakes but I'm
thinking I hope you like my radians